alright here's a big one finish the
syncadapter making it fetch the weather
and store it in the database alter the
update weather function within the
forecast fragment to start a sync with
the sync adapter some hints here pull
the code from on handle intent into our
sync adapter on handle intent is inside
of our sunshine service the good news is
that abstract threaded sync adapter
provides a background thread to run the
server fetch on just like intent service
does also just fetch the location query
from our utility class eventually we
want to run syncs like this without any
involvement of the user finally make the
sync adapter run when we call update
weather